[Music]
on this Friday night judgment day for a
Toronto police officer guilty of a
beating that left a young black man
blinded in one eye that's a show
appreciation for the community you
supported me Michael Cobb Rick's wife
amps up the pressure he should not have
to suffer anymore for something he has
not done will Ottawa get tougher with
Beijing answering the calls and cries
for help so this is definitely not been
a normal year the Kids Help Phone takes
unprecedented measures and the sports
world pandemic playbook there are going
to be some people who get sick how to
get back in the game after this unusual
intermission
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
reporting tonight
Robin Gill good evening and thank you
for joining us we begin with the verdict
in a case involving a violent
confrontation between a black teenager
and off-duty Toronto police officer and
his brother an Ontario judge has found
constable Michael Theriot guilty of
assault Christian tario was acquitted of
the assault charge as well as a charge
of obstruction of justice
the brothers were accused of chasing 19
year-old dafonte Miller and beating him
so badly with a pipe Miller lost his
left eye Global Salima Maharaj is
following the developments to Lima what
do we know about how the judge arrived
at his decision well Robin there was
already a great deal of attention
surrounding the trial of Toronto police
constable Michael Theriot and his
brother Christian the Focus has since
become amplified Justice Joseph DeLuca
acknowledged the social context
surrounding this case but that it wasn't
his task to conduct a public inquiry
into race and policing or to deliver a
verdict sought by the public it's been
more than three years since a violent
altercation changed the course of de
Fonteyn Miller's life now at the
conclusion of the trial - the two men
accused of beating him we've come a long
way you know because I remember tonight
when you're talking to me and I love
getting charged you know and now we're
in a situation where an officer has been
held accountable to some extent justice
Joseph DeLuca read out his 62 page
judgement via YouTube it took more than
four hours the brothers were charged
with aggravated assault and obstruction
of justice
Christian tario was acquitted on both
counts while Toronto police constable
Michael Theriot was found guilty of the
lesser charge of assault how could it
happen that neither the Toronto Police
Service nor the Durham Regional Police
Service in view of these catastrophic
injuries never contacted the Special
Investigations Unit
Ontario's police watchdog was eventually
contacted by Miller's lawyer Julien
Falconer after months had already gone
by during the trial the defense argued
the brothers caught Miller
and his friends breaking into their
parents pickup truck the court heard the
brothers alleged Miller attacked them
and they acted in self-defense
in his testimony Miller said he saw the
longer haired man Michael tario an
off-duty cop wielding a pipe he also
told the court he was struck with that
object justice DeLuca was satisfied that
he was hit in the face with the pipe but
he also accepted the assertion of a
medical expert but the injury to
Miller's left eye which had to be
surgically removed was likely the result
of a punch at the end
DeLuca could not conclude guilt beyond a
reasonable doubt on the aggravated
assault and obstruction charges the
crowd outside the courthouse appeared
extremely deflated when the judge told
Christian tario that he was free to go
Michael tario on the other hand is due
back in court in July Robyn Selena
Maharaja in Toronto the case among Wong
Jo is dominating headlines again tonight
defense and security experts are now
urging the federal government to ignore
calls for a prisoner swap prime minister
Justin Trudeau says his government is
working diplomatic channels to get
Michael Kovarik and Michael SPAWAR
out of a Chinese jail without buckling
to foreign pressure cough Rick's wife
spoke to global news about the 18
agonizing months he spent behind bars
Michael Couture has the story it's
already been five hundred and sixty-five
days he should not have to suffer any
more for something he has not done you
can hear the desperation in viña
Najibullah michael caverns wife broke
her silence this week demanding the
Canadian government do more to bring her
husband and Michael's pavor home the two
are separated but she has been his
advocate for months in an interview on
the West block with Mercedes Stevenson
and Ebola says our government needs to
be more forceful we need more leverage
we need more space to maneuver and
hopefully the conversations of this week
have opened up a little bit more space
for that most of that conversation
centered around a prisoner swap the two
Michael's in exchange for huawei CFO
among Wong's Oh the idea was suggested
in a letter penned by 19 prominent
Canadians was promptly quashed by Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau and another
group of
33 who wrote an alternative missive
saying Canada needs to stand up to China
if we permit China to reorganize the
international order under their model we
will see a walk back of the post-war
order from 1945 in ways that we've only
begun to imagine but the group was
suggesting applying Magnitsky sanctions
which focus on human rights abuses
against Chinese officials responsible
for the detention of coverage and spa
for asked about it again Trudeau tried
to be reassuring we have established
processes some public some private and
diplomatic behind the scenes that
maximize our chances of bringing these
Canadians in difficulty home case of the
drew Michaels because they're being
delight denied their diplomatic status
to the International Court of Justice
bring together a team of international
jurists does that would draw attention
to it you know keep the pressure on
China they hate being embarrassed it's
just another option our government might
pursue behind closed doors while
covering and spa for continued to wait
behind bars Robin
Michael Couture in Ottawa thanks Mike
and you can watch the extended interview
with Michael kovorix wife this Sunday on
the west lock with Mercedes Stevenson
right here on global a charity
associated with the prime minister's
wife will dole out grants to student
volunteers this summer Justin Trudeau
says the whe charity was the best option
to administer the Canada Student Service
grant the program will provide eligible
students with up to five thousand
dollars for post-secondary education
depending on volunteer hours worked in
the fight against Kovan 19 Sophie
Gregoire Trudeau is an ambassador of the
charity but the prime minister says the
nonpartisan civil service made the
choice not him they came back and
demonstrated that really the we
organization is the only organization in
Canada that has the scale and the
ability to deliver volunteer
opportunities for young people right
across the country at all levels of
organizations Trudeau adds the charity
will not profit off the administration
of the grant program Quebec will resume
its daily Cova 19 up
starting next week the province was
criticized after announcing it would be
only once a week even though it's still
the worst-hit province in the country
most of the deaths there have been in
long-term care homes now the Canadian
Red Cross is sending in 900 people as
the military begins to withdraw members
of the Canadian Armed Forces have been
providing support in care homes since
April Quebec Premier France while ago
had urged the military to keep at least
a thousand members in homes until the
fall the federal government says a small
contingent will remain until the Cova 19
situation is stable but I want to be
clear the Canadian Armed Forces will not
leave a facility until it is stable
before leaving these facilities they
will again ensure that conditions are
stable and that staff are well equipped
to continue to meet their residents
needs the care homes endure deadly
outbreaks of the novel coronavirus as
well as staffing shortages there are now
16 confirmed Cova 19 cases linked to an
outbreak at a nail salon in Kingston
Ontario public health officials have
closed the business until further notice
six workers including the owner have
tested positive for the virus along with
ten other people public health officials
say some employees came to work while
symptomatic physical distancing at the
salon was also an issue and the business
did not keep accurate records of its
clients the World Health Organization
says it needs more than 31 billion
dollars over the next 12 months to
develop and rollout Cova 19 tests
treatments and vaccines we know testing
is critical in the fight against the
pandemic as countries around the world
continue to see a surge in cases here's
a look at some of the new concerning
hotspots Japan has recorded more than a
hundred new cases in one day its highest
daily total since May 9th overall there
are now more than 18 thousand cases
there Mexico is recording more than two
hundred and two thousand total cases
with more than 25,000 deaths Italy has
sent soldiers to a coastal town near
Naples after an outbreak at an apartment
complex
hundreds of migrant workers living there
ended up in confrontations with
residents about 50 people living in the
and in buildings have tested positive
for the virus the u.s. vice-president
who leads the White House's coronavirus
task force says all 50 states and
territories are opening up safely and
responsibly despite the fact that cases
have searched in at least 32 states as
Jennifer Johnson reports younger
Americans now account for an
ever-growing percentage of infections
members of the White House coronavirus
task force briefed Americans for the
first time since late April as new cases
of copán 19 have broken records all week
the increase is skyrocketing among 18 to
34 year olds in states like Florida
Texas Arizona and California doctors
pleading with young adults to be more
careful
the chances are that if you get infected
that you're going to infect someone else
and then ultimately you will infect
someone who's vulnerable in Florida all
bars have been ordered closed after that
state hit a record-high
close to nine thousand new cases bars
closed in Texas - and governor Greg
Abbott has placed new limits on
businesses and services as the infection
rate in his state won over 10 percent
ICU beds in Houston are full doctors in
several other states are also sounding
the alarm I'm absolutely terrified that
we're gonna overwhelm the health care
system the hospitals and ICU not in the
fall which is something had worried me
previously but now I'm worried about
next week notably absent from the
briefing US President Donald Trump who
continues to blame the rapid increases
on more testing Vice President Mike
Pence spent close to a half hour
boasting about how well the Trump
administration has handled the pandemic
we have made a truly remarkable progress
in moving our nation forward but doctors
are now warning parents and grandparents
to be on alert you know if you have
comorbidities you know if you're over 80
we asked you if in these hot spots in
these states that are having expansion
in cases to continue to shelter as much
as you can
hundreds of jurisdictions across the
country are now mandating masks we can
be either part of the solution or part
of the problem the taskforce doctor is
telling Americans especially Millennials
to step up all Prakash
masks physical distancing in
hand-washing as the us death toll
continues to rise Jennifer Johnson
Global News Washington the Supreme Court
of Canada has upheld a ruling that gives
Ober drivers the green light to take on
the company the decision opens the door
to a 400 million-dollar class action
lawsuit against uber it's the next step
in a fight for drivers to be recognized
as employees not contract workers the
suit is aimed at securing minimum wage
vacation pay and other benefits and
Global News has confirmed Amazon Canada
is facing a 200 million dollar
class-action lawsuit involving delivery
drivers the suit was filed on behalf of
about 2,500 people there seeking damages
over alleged unpaid wages including
overtime vacation and meal breaks the
class-action says drivers work for
courier companies contracted by Amazon
to deliver parcels but the online retail
giant is their true employer Amazon
Canada says we disagree with the
allegations and expect to fully disprove
them a violent attack in the heart of
Glasgow coming up the rampage that sent
several people including a police
officer to hospital plus loss and likely
never to be found the newest piece of
space junk floating around
six men are in hospital tonight
including a police officer after a
violent attack in Scotland
it happened at a hotel in Glasgow's
downtown core the suspect was quickly
shot and killed by police investigators
say this is not terrorism related but as
your bureau chief crystal commencing
explains they're still searching for a
motive
loud racing police vehicles quickly
clogged Glasgow City Centre this is a
seedy situation and none of us need to
make it worse by shooting it's
speculative accounts of what happened
the investigation is not terror related
but disturbing nonetheless it happened
at Park Inn Radisson Hotel Group
confirms to global news that the hotel
was being used for temporary housing
during the pandemic and says we are
deeply saddened by the tragic event that
happened today on West George Street in
Glasgow we are working with the hotel
owner and all of the relevant local
authorities when dreadful things like
this happen be shocked all of us to a
court but above all this should remind
us of what unites us and not what
divides us video posted to social media
by witnesses shows a chaotic scene
authorities say all of the victims are
men officers were on the scene within
two minutes and armed officers shortly
afterwards in the incident was quickly
a man was shot by armed police and have
subsequently died six other men in
hospital for treatment including the 42
year old police officer who was in a
critical but stable condition as the
investigation continues police have not
yet shared what prompted the attack or
any details about the man killed crystal
de Manson Global News London a british
teen will spend at least the next 15
years behind bars for throwing a child
off a museum balcony
eighteen-year-old John T bravery was
sentenced today after being convicted of
attempted murder last August he tossed
the six year-old boy from a tenth floor
viewing platform at London's Tate Modern
Art Gallery at the time he told police
he did it because he wanted to be on the
news
the child survived the 30-meter fall but
suffered a brain injury and various
broken bones he's now in a wheelchair
still ahead the calls for emotional
support and the Canadians so answer you
are watching global national
see that wrist mirror a matching one is
now orbiting in space it detached from
astronaut Chris Cassidy spacesuit right
as he exited the International Space
Station he was setting out for a
seven-hour venture with veteran space
Walker Rob bankin to replace batteries
on a power channel on the way he added
some space junk which nASA says won't
pose a threat the collateral damage from
this pandemic is the heavy toll on our
mental health
a new survey this week found 84 percent
of respondents reported their mental
health concerns had worsened since the
outbreak and as Geoff sample reports
thousands of Canadians are now stepping
up to offer support to those in need
Ashley Cummings has struggled with her
mental health and depression since she
was a kid and the kovat 19 pandemic
hasn't been easy it just creates so many
different points of stress and and you
get wrapped up in those thoughts but
when that stress becomes too much
Cummings reaches for her lifeline a text
message conversation with an anonymous
stranger from kids helpful thank you for
calling Kids Help Phone how can I help
you the charity has provided youth
counseling services for three decades
typically contacted by around 400 young
people every day but that was before the
biggest mental health crisis the
organization has ever seen so this is
definitely not been a normal year the
pandemic and lockdown saw demand for
kids help phone services skyrocket up
three hundred and fifty percent young
people across Canada are seen heightened
anxiety you know Phil Ian's of isolation
overwhelmed kids help phone called for
backup
asking ordinary Canadians to volunteer
to provide emotional support over text
message it was a big ask kids help phone
volunteers are required to undergo a 36
hour training course a police background
check and then provide support to young
people who in some cases have endured
terrible suffering and abuse so in March
we put a call out and the response was
overwhelming we had almost nine thousand
Canadians raised their hand and say that
they wanted to
part of supporting young people which to
me was huge one of those volunteers says
it's been a win-win there's very few
volunteer opportunities I believe that
you can walk at the end of your shift or
walk at the end your day and say well I
potentially saved someone's life today
and thanks to those volunteers for the
first time in its history Kids Help
Phone is now extending its services to
adults we've seen over the time of kovat
an increasing number of adults reaching
out saying they have nowhere to go but
that support is now just a text message
away
just simple Global News Toronto anyone
who needs mental health support can
reach kids help phone by calling texting
or going online the service is available
24 hours a day and as we mentioned it's
for kids and adults
up next risk versus reward the faceoff
of the return of pro sports in a
pandemic two weeks from today
NHL training camps are scheduled to get
underway but exactly where and how the
players will return to the ice remains
unclear and time is of the essence the
league has said the playoffs will take
place in hubs some Canadian cities were
vying to host the games Vancouver was
believed to be a top pick but as Eric
Sorenson explains it's no longer in the
running Vancouver illustrates the
dilemma in playing hockey and keeping
healthy it's a big city with Cova 19
well under control but no longer being
considered as one of the two hubs for
NHL playoffs the decision follows bc's
commitment to health protocols that
could have stopped play after a positive
test under no circumstances was I going
to compromise in any way the health of
people here in British Columbia and we
made that very clear some fans are
disappointed but many support the
decision I think a lot of people would
rather have a cautious approach to this
rather than trying to you know have an
issue you know flare up again Edmonton
is one of two Canadian cities still in
the running
Toronto is the other Las Vegas is a
frontrunner south of the border but
kovat 19 is suddenly spiking in the
United
States the last week has been a really
troubling one so I would say right now
the NHL and other professional sports
league leaders are very nervous NHL
players have been skating in small
groups but there is uncertainty before
training camps begin
Montreal's star goaltender Carey Price
says he still wants answers to questions
others are optimistic a kovat free
bubble can be created I've been involved
in a lot of talks and I'm pretty
confident that once we get into hub
cities we'll be able to do a good job of
keeping it out and golf competitors can
keep their distance a single case may be
isolated with less fear of spreading the
virus but team sports with a lot of
physical contact is a huge challenge the
NBA has decided to restart in July at
the Disney World Complex in Florida even
though that state is now a kovat 19
hotspot and 16 players just tested
positive Major League Baseball plans a
shortened season beginning next month
after players tested positive the
Toronto Blue Jays shut down their
Florida training facility there are
skeptics the idea that you can assure
the safety of any professional sport is
beyond my comprehension others say it's
time to try there's going to be risk at
this point there's going to be positive
tests there are going to be some people
who get sick but at some point we have
to reopen society and get going
big league sports will start again this
summer but will they be able to finish
Erik Sorensen Global News Toronto and
that is global national for this Friday
I'm Robin Gill tonight your Canada is
Bowring Park in st. John's Newfoundland
and Labrador we'd love to see your
corner of this country so email your
pictures to viewers at global national
calm thank you for watching and I'll see
you back here tomorrow have a great
night
[Music]